hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to baldies your real basics
in education and learning this is a real
remake or a real fan game it's got some
kind of [ __ ] about remembrance
control forget all about her and summer
camp and I don't know what this is in
relation to but it should be fun should
be fun
might be fun it could be fun
Oh their individualized chapters as in
their each their own kind of game let's
pump it up - fantastic oh I really want
to test my computer system here bring it
on Baldy been a while oh boy I got
Slender Man vibes out of this one hello
I can't move I can't go this way oh god
why can't I go this way well I guess
we're just gonna go dis way then into
the bush Oh around the bush oh I'm an
idiot I thought I thought it was an
impenetrable bush fool on me the
impenetrable thing was the open field no
whatever
hey look so deep ah if only I had a
corridor or two I guess I'm in the
school now hey teach hello-o become a
samurai today pretty sure that's how you
do it what is it what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
me then okay ah so it is kind of a
remake oh well [ __ ] I almost got outside
I guess what the [ __ ] did I just said oh
hey hey oh don't like this let's do I
Oh jumbo Jack's sure is great sometime
soon okay all right
oh god this head Bob Jesus Christ is
that Bob I'm gonna get nauseous with
this head Bob and apparently I can get a
number of warnings down at the bottom
left okay here we go
I can't wait for this Baldy hello
[Music]
oh this is much worse also what I just
got a thousand flashbacks from hearing
that one smack my ass is Stewart and my
ass is a tingling from all the smacks
I've gotten in the past Baldy plays oh
hey Baldy oh no you dyes orrible no it's
horrible horrible horrible thing
horrible horrible in every way I hate
this why am I still standing here okay
goodbye
Jay zooms okay can I run kind of I don't
seem to have a run be me B meter Peter
meter beater I don't seem to have a run
meter so I'm assuming I can just run
forever without problem yeah I can't run
in the halls why did that Wow [ __ ] me
you big-lipped bastard
all right notebook
well 56 got it nailed it I'm smart
you're dumb well if it's just that easy
hi you're not even gonna give me a
pretend one what's [ __ ] why are you
doing doing a pirouette around me
screw you what is this can I have this
you can only carry one item is that what
I'm okay well that is just goddamn
terrifying
okay else I was gonna take this game
kind of like not so seriously but this
one this is legit terrifying and I don't
know why well I know why I don't know
what was up with that face thing I've
never seen that face thing before but it
just passed right through me well the
layout is kinda similar but also very
different from the other one so I'm
gonna be I'm probably gonna be lost for
a little bit oh I see well that's
ominous and scary I don't even know what
that is sound of no poker is that that's
I'm bad who the hell what's not oh
that's weird and oh we were
Oh a notebook out here in the middle of
nothingness I guess all right
well got that one sure am half a doodle
e-app oh ho ho ho about all that so I
think it's like a grid right it's just a
series of square areas and this is oh I
don't know what that is but that don't
look good all right so I got
funkalicious feeling that that ooh bad
baldies gonna be spanking my rumpus any
time soon okay
two dollars all right what the [ __ ] is
that what is that oh god I don't even
know where anything is okay so there's
lockers there governor I've been here
already
okay so it seems like there's kind of
five or four different lateral hallways
I think five included what am I looking
at oh that's the pulley I don't want the
bully not the bully anything but the
bully or anything but you and Baldy I
see you down there okay well this is
problematic okay
all right so we got these five lateral
hallways I don't think there was
anything on the outside so let me tuck
in this one I'm just gonna go oopsy
poopsy up and down them until I can find
the way I need to go that's a problem I
wonder if sweepy man's gonna come by oh
[ __ ] you are not fun alright so that was
one of a way okay it's fun okay
hi what are you doing what are you doing
what are you talking at the first one to
where that dude where the heck er all of
the everything okay I came up that one
so I'm if I go down this one well it's
not oh boy dumpy dumpy dumpy dumpy
I'm the dumpy you're a dumpy oh you're a
jumpring hey hey I can still look behind
me there's a notebook in there outside
that oh I thought that was faces just
plants okay so three this is kind of
good because usually three of seven I
can't even walk away from them you
always have to run so the the
requirements aren't so tight what do you
what are you what are you what are you
why why why why what are you what are
you who are you what are you looking at
me hey oh you're getting pushed
uh-oh are you a tattletale that just
tells Baldy where I is cuz that's not
cool all right so I'm gonna circle
around oh [ __ ]
all right good get this BLAP BLAP BLAP
okay got that okay I'm gonna go this way
continue down here grab these two things
that'll be enough to get one more so Dee
I guess if I need that there's more so D
whoa okay you're fine there what about
in here okay okay we're doing so good
we're doing so good we're doing so good
we're doing so good maybe hey okay
there's my mom oh boy that's not cool
don't know what that's about we're doing
so good wait what that mean oh [ __ ] that
mean these first two wait that would
mean there would be two in here right it
would be two in here how close is Baldy
close people go hey hi
okay all right hey while you're doing
that I'm uh there is one in here there
is one in here there's I have five money
when did I get five money I wasn't
running Oh shitty tits why why
[Music]
well I've got another problem besides
that hey Baldy hi ha [ __ ] well that was
much more terrifying than I ever thought
it could be so ha ha ha ho I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to get her through
all this but let's try this one again I
almost had that no 6 to 7 I didn't run I
didn't think I ran I didn't think I ran
but apparently I did
so actually I'm gonna save these two for
the end of the game and then I'm gonna
go for the rest first you know what I
mean
I got ma I'm not in trouble quite yet
what I'm a little concerned for my
safety that's today oh I don't like the
way you're illuminating yeah Oh got you
baby probably probably being bald is the
is the basis of success and and winning
that's how winning uh oh [ __ ] um that's
how winning is done
so if I go on who's opening doors who's
opening doors who's opening doors I
don't like you oh why that's why that is
why oh that's why oh okay I have five
money and I don't know how I got five
money but I have five money six money
now so one of them is worth like four so
that's good to know
I think he's following where I owe you
not it's bloosh okay that's probably
gonna work real good Lee it looks like
it's gonna be in the exact same places
that it was before so that's not a big
deal I just missed that one
that was near him that I got a circle
back for before I get the two in the
beginning of it or am I wrong about that
I might be wrong about that is this just
coin or is this
that's coin but okay good uh I guess
that's good so I'm gonna go around the
outside here it's not well it's not
let's not do that right you know what I
might actually I might actually go for
these two here I don't know where Baldy
is right now but I appreciate their
their commitment to recreating things
not just like ripping oh [ __ ] well this
is gonna be okay
Kizer no no no no no no okay I don't
know why you're not getting me but
you're not and I appreciate that I'm
okay I'm okay no running into a house I
think I can get this though it doesn't
seem as hard unless like right let's
play unless like right as he hits I get
seven notebooks he becomes like an
unbeatable which is an entire pot can
you all shut up I'm trying to talk we
might become an unbeatable nightmare but
I don't think that's gonna be the case
let's not oh [ __ ] oh oh oh oh that's
okay it seems like he's stuck on the
bully actually oh well that's good I'm
uh I'm gonna take advantage of that Oh
sounds like he might have gotten out of
the bully oh well [ __ ] okay so if he
pops in here I'm just gonna hoof it and
blam him with my soda pop
me that oh [ __ ] that sounds fast
that sounds real fast okay you're gonna
get up okay you're gonna go that way and
I've got one more left that's all I
gotta get I just got to get one more
left
okay I guess the soda doesn't go for
very long then alright let's let's play
a gun
sometimes just the way those things come
out of the shadows ain't fun at all okay
so they are in the exact same place
that's good to know
okay they're in the same place no matter
what alright so I went up this one now I
go down there I go down this one and
then I go up the middle and then I go
down the middle I'm gonna do this one no
there's none in here show you don't come
out of the darkness like that that's so
scary
hmmm like looking behind you know
probably they couldn't figure out how to
do the jumping rope mechanic so just how
to do jeez just had to do what you got
to do with what you got make sense
though to me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh I did
why didn't I grab one oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine listen listen buddy
listen listen
hey listen and one two three four five
six okay
this is okay I've got four of seven I
probably missed something in de Moodle
because I'm an idiot
but it's okay cuz I'm gonna stick to my
plan and then if I if I miss one I know
it's in the middle right I know it's in
the middle it's kind of [ __ ] because
now I have to go up and down one more
time but that's okay
the whole thing about plans is that
they're [ __ ] and you got to be
adaptable to whatever you need that's
not you doe hey ah hi
Baldy hey listen how about a cool
refreshing sody pop to keep your mind
off of how much you want to murder me
let's not [ __ ] oh I thought that was
something down here okay yeah oh you're
doing good oh he's getting sloppy he's
getting real sloppy oh he's getting real
sloppy oh sorry
don't you goddamn dare don't you frickin
dare don't you freakin real fast
okay all right so I got to do I'm
assuming I got to do the thing where I
gotta go to the exits and they're not
gonna be real Oh God
well maybe I just got to go out the
front maybe I don't know he's probably
gonna got me I can't hear a goddamn
thing
oh [ __ ] that's really fast oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I gotta go for the soda pop I gotta
go
come on come on boy under the camo
well that didn't go well but that's okay
cuz now I think I think maybe I just
have to go to the beginning
hey I don't like you I think you just
have to go to the beginning and I think
the money is random whenever you get it
and I gotta make sure that when I'm at
the end I have one soda in and then I'm
near another one so I think where I
ended it last time was actually a good
place it says I didn't use my soda I
didn't use my toady Bobby properly
hearing the whistle Wessel would be
great oh she's right in front of me
isn't she god she's so she's got like a
homing beacon honor
ah that's the cafeteria okay where is he
okay he's there so I can spare one of
these just cuz I want to get some
distance I don't have one of those wait
oh [ __ ] I do not get me do not make me
do the thing I'm just gonna get this now
cuz I can't nothin yarder did you grab
one of these blast him I'm gonna brush
[ __ ] not this way I'm gonna blast him
this way do not make me do this
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks
yeah let's do it sometime soon yeah I
know where the last one is okay
I got a Saudi I've got money for Saudi
and I just got to make my way back I'm
kinda at the wrong place but whatever
you know the whole begging and choosing
thing you know that whole deal okay all
right all right
um again I'm getting I'm get going I'm
going get it
I've got to go Wow [ __ ] it doesn't work
oh [ __ ] okay it is the way there is is
this not showing it back
okay let's try that again and this time
we're gonna not die
this is Weldon this is well-made this is
really well-made I got to admit this is
well well well made yeah I thought that
was the dude oh please oh oh come on my
advantage
oh there he is that's really cool huh
all right whatever I'm fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's for you
oh hi that's terrible
[Music]
you should still be so dude you should
have still it [ __ ] okay you gotta get
him farther away from me you just gotta
[ __ ] man this is tougher than I thought
it'd be let me just grab one of these
suits
well did I just waste - what but I
didn't want to waste - I only wanted to
use one
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where is he where is he
I don't know where I oh oh [ __ ] okay
there's that I wasn't I'm just gonna run
I don't care [ __ ] it I'm dead anyway
what does it matter let me out [ __ ]
I'm done so oh I don't have anything -
[ __ ] - [ __ ] - [ __ ] well that went wrong
but even if you glance what the [ __ ]
it's like there was no the sock
transported me and that ruined
everything I had no idea where I was oh
so he still loses distance even if he's
at six of seven he's still losing you so
that's good to know I wonder if it's
still the same way where he can actually
lose sight of you if you don't go
through a doorway and he loses like
contact a line of sight for a little bit
cuz there is a doorway there and I'm
wondering if that has anything to do
with like an actual line of sight thing
of course well you know shouldn't have
even tried to be grateful should I have
no I shouldn't have nah that wouldn't
work that well for me no matter what I
did that was gonna be bad here he is all
my lead that I just got has gone up in
smoke that's thank you for that I just
don't think there's enough
[Music]
hi jesus [ __ ] christ
are you [ __ ] kidding me sim my god is
so [ __ ] so that's just like it'll
happen no matter what that's going to
happen like if you even glance at that
thing like alright I guess this is what
it is this is what it is huh this is
what it is okay last one I don't hear
him a smacking so that's kind of good
she's gonna yep there she is
Oh if you oh if you get me in here I
will be what fat [ __ ]
Oh where's I guess I just got to touch
him I don't know there's not a lot of
feedback on that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh shitty
tits no hi penny
sodas anywhere well that saves me for a
second
I'm done so I'm done so I'm done so I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
okay so I can't go that way because
there's just no there's no soda machines
that way but if I go down then I get
that one in the cafeteria that I didn't
haven't been in it's since I first tried
this game [ __ ] this is how this always
goes though this always goes like I get
into it I'm like oh it's cool it's cool
and then I'm get so [ __ ] pissed off
[Music]
that's how you can tell it's an
authentic Baldy game cuz it's like oh
this could be fun
oh I hate life that's just how it goes
that's a recipe just leave just leave
just leave just leave just go just leave
leave
[Music]
don't circle back are you kidding me are
you kidding me are you [ __ ] kidding
me
oh [ __ ] no it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine I just want this money just
wanted to come here for the money
God give it up lady no not now not there
go away just go I'm gonna take this I'm
gonna take this I'm gonna go here and
I'm gonna get this last one and then I'm
gonna do the thing that I meant to do
which is just go the route that I know
will lead me to another oh whoa whoa
Jesus oh [ __ ] that oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
little
you're gonna make me oh where am I what
the [ __ ] okay that's fun oh just just
let me die
not that one huh Oh God it went the
wrong way ah well she Oh [ __ ] she's
still after me huh
that's cool that's real cool oh boy I
don't know
back
oh it doesn't aspect
all right that's great oh you don't even
need to type in anything well that's fun
okay good to know
okay there's a soda right in there but
he's not in the best place for this but
I don't care because at this point I'm
just I'm just so sick of everything but
I'm just gonna blast him
I'm gonna grab this one
when I grab this one gonna blast him
again now is much closer than I had
hoped it would be
oh hi okay well that's alright cuz now I
can try this and it's real [ __ ] up I
[ __ ] it up ah [ __ ] I could have had
that cousin I could have gone right to
the kitchen like this thing that would
have wouldn't that would have been
perfect that would have been great
because then I could have right going
right to the kitchen I could have cut
across the [ __ ] of it those sodas do
not last as long as they need to know
okay that's fine that's fine that's fine
that's fine nope how about a big nope on
that wall hate this I hate this I hate
it I hate it I hate it I hate it I hate
it I hate this I hate this I hate this I
hate it I hate it I hate it I hate this
hate hate is in my soul hate hate hate
hate hate I hate this it hates me I hate
it back it hates me back I give it hate
it gives me hates hate hate hate hate
hate hate hate burning hatred nothing
but hate hate hate hate hate I'm a hater
I've been known to give a hate I've come
from Haiti okay here we go
he's a good bit away and I'm right next
to one of them but that's a problem oh
boy you've got to be fun
no no no [ __ ] off oh no I [ __ ] of
course you would be right there the
second I run
[Music]
Oh No why
I have no idea where he is
I think I hear him there is enough
hopefully that worked oh [ __ ] no oh no
no no no no no you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
Oh member jambo Mamba Jamba whoa boy
whoa Danny Boy boy oh boy this game sure
does like the dick with me
boy oh boy I've never felt a good
[ __ ] like this before Charles Dickens
couldn't have anything on the amount of
dick a tree that's happening in this
game right now I can I'm flabbergasted
by the sheer quantity of dick that I'm
being force-fed at this juncture
oh yeah Baldy comes down that way that's
why I don't go down that way anymore
because it's a deathtrap that's right I
remember it [ __ ] me so hard
oh hell oh here we go
[Applause]
not like that you [ __ ] why of all the
places of all the places you could have
gone out of why did you have to cut
through there Oh of all the places I had
that so perfectly [ __ ] there we go
he's gonna come through same place same
place same place oh I didn't even have a
soda I forgot to get his shoulder Bob we
forgot to eat a soda pop oh I forgot
about that one Oh silly me I just
oops didn't grab it didn't grab a
goddamn soda pop that's my bad I'm
drooling that's fine you know what that
is fine I'm okay with that
that is a hundred percent a okay in my
book
you know everyone makes mistakes
especially me always me but everyone
makes mistakes and you know I can't be
blaming myself
be it just because I didn't grab that
[Music]
everyone makes mistakes and you know
life is about learning from those
mistakes it's not about blaming yourself
no matter how much you need to blame
yourself because you're a [ __ ] idiot
but it's a matter of how much you can
forgive yourself because you're a
[ __ ] idiot you know you know what I
mean you know what I mean yeah you know
what I mean you all of you know what I
mean everyone knows what I mean
hi there you go you got the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] what the
flying [ __ ] are you if that ruins me
because now that the can that I was
waiting on I can't [ __ ] he's gonna
take it if I go that you are [ __ ]
follow you are [ __ ] follow oh my god
oh god my patience is [ __ ] running
the [ __ ] out my patience is running the
[ __ ] out
no you [ __ ] and then you it's how you
made me miss you made me [ __ ] miss
you made me [ __ ] mess
god [ __ ] damnit I'm just gonna end
that happens okay well that's good I got
I didn't grab to I hit it twice
accidentally there we go whatever that's
not gonna work is it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] me
oh you gotta be
all right it's fine it's fine it's fine
cuz my strategy is still good it just
hasn't been able to be executed because
of millions of coincidences who the [ __ ]
is calling me [ __ ] calm like a river
like a flowing river of [ __ ] just [ __ ]
pouring out of my mouth of my ears nose
eyes and butthole know everything except
my butthole because why would that be
right
everything should be wrong when I'm
flowing poopy out of every part of my
body everything needs to be wrong
because everything is wrong in this
goddamn game and I am going to lose my
mind
5 to deal with another layer of [ __ ]
I've got the Saudi and here comes the
lady everything's fine everything's
[ __ ] fine everything's fine oh so
what I want is plenty of space between
me and him that's all I want and I've
got that thankfully right here ok here
we go
[Music]
I'm not gonna Oh what the [ __ ] weird it
away [ __ ] don't run don't run
run
[Music]
okay that was a thing that definitely
happened
[ __ ] I've already gotten this one [ __ ]
me then I'm gonna go for another soda
running god damnit why is that bully
right there
where's the kind of friend I don't know
where he's coming from but he's nearby
there is what okay just gonna try to do
this
okay I guess one more I guess
it's gonna get it I'm gonna get it no
I'm not gonna I'm gonna get it yes
[ __ ] yes where am I going
yeah
[Music]
doesn't bail wasn't worth it that was
now I feel bad
I don't feel good I feel my god but it's
okay I did it hey look at that I did it
I got to celebrate where I got to
celebrating we're gonna celebrate right
here so thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this if you
want me to play the other ones no I know
maybe I don't know maybe I'll feel
better about it I just if there are any
different I don't know if they would be
I'm not a hundred percent sure control
what does that even mean
schools basement oh god they are
different that all about her oh good you
know what fine and sober cap so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought in the comments
below if you want to support the channel
hit that joined button and we're going
on tour in Australia in November which
is in two months so if you're in
Australia or New Zealand and want to see
us live and in person us meaning me and
all my friends check out the link in the
description below or go to tor dot
market lawyer calm and check out for
yourself thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye